so royal indian cities let's
see if there's anything
interesting here
well don't get involved
yes you can also take the six that
's uncomfortable
yes ok climate this position is actually
always a little bit better for white
but can play this pawn sacrifice which
i think  by the way, opponent wanted to
look at jimmy smurf also from
germany 10 226 so at least
the moves are easy to play at first
so prophylaxis so works now anyway
maybe the 5 well is at least
consistent
then of course i didn’t
really expect it stupid move so
stupid for  black i
still got a pawn
server
yes what to do is just one pawn
less nothing at all and i have a
weak reason in can not now
next to victor to eight and runner 6
now he hangs first petereit well it's
really really simple too  not to
play
yes what should he pull the c3 you
don't want to play do who moves in also
kom  it looks so passive if
you want the meter thick and sound c7
i can really hit b3 first
then maybe
i have short chances myself on the basis also has closed
the passive so maybe the
jumper the seven jumper digits
so that's what i thought  now maybe a
knight e5 and he doesn't have the
super great squares for the queen he
also has to thicken the rook
so that you have to do f4 again on your heart so
thun be 5 well
I'll
try to get on with a4
he fell badly too  I'll try quite a bit
folks but I just wanted to save
the basic row again
that's maybe
not so stupid after all like a4
so now maybe also a 3
because that's now here's
actually enough activity
I can play atom b1 or  there are
shafts and springer c 41 yes no
idea yet somehow always
present
a bit a bit of compensation
somehow you only have it practically  not easy to
play for him